it's hard to when you say that to some
people because they say oh there you go
with it pull yourself up by the
bootstraps thing and you know you're
just being respectable not everybody can
do that
everybody can
courage
courage is the key to life itself there
are a lot of people who are born in
situations with survive just I'll never
get out of this so they won't
I say to people who say well I would
like to have done so and so and so so we
could have done it so but I couldn't get
out of here
man the bus runs every day
I thought what you said was fascinating
because you called it ball when you said
people can't you know pull themselves up
do you think that race plays a part in
wealth distribution or either a mindset
that you can't true they cannot yeah no
you don't no I don't I know you and I
we're proof why would race have anything
to do with it stick you put your mind to
what you want to do and go for that